-He a three-time NBA champion,
and she is a two-time
New York Times
bestselling author.
Together, they host
and executive produce
a new game show called
"About Last Night,"
which premieres
February 10th on HBO Max.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome
Stephen and Ayesha Curry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
Hey!
-Hello.
-Steph, Ayesha.
Great to see you both.
Thanks for doing this.
I appreciate it.
I have some questions
for you guys,
because you've been married --
You've been married
for 10 years,
but you've known
each other for 20 years.
You guys -- since your kids.
-20?
-That's about true.
We're getting old.
[ Laughs ]
-We're about to hit 20.
-I want to know what your first
impressions of each other were.
Ayesha, you can go first.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, it's so funny.
I -- I was maybe 14 years old
when we first met,
and I just remember
thinking he was so cute
and my family being like,
"He looks like your brother."
I don't see it.
For whatever reason,
every -- all of our family.
Listen, we took 23andMe test,
we're in the clear.
Everything's fine.
[ Laughter ]
-You're not brother and sister,
yeah.
-We're not, no.
I don't see it.
There was no rumors
about that going around, yeah.
And Steph, what do you
remember about Ayesha?
-I mean, I knew she was
beautiful.
We were both shy, so we didn't
know really how to, you know,
talk to each other
and approach each other.
But I also knew
she was from Canada,
and my dad played for the
Raptors for a little bit
when I lived up there.
I love Canadian candy,
and so she was the candy plug
for a long time
before we even started.
Just bring back candy
from Canada
and we'll get off
to a good start.
-Yeah.
Ayesha, I heard that you had
a dating policy or something
where you wrote out a thing on
who you wanted
to be like your dream date,
and on the thing
it said no athletes.
-It did in capital letters.
I don't know why this was
a high school activity
that the theater teacher
had us do,
but she had us
write down
what we were looking for
in a significant other.
It was "High School Musical"
days.
I was in my feelings,
and I wrote that on there.
So it's like
one of those things
be careful what you say,
because God definitely
has a sense of humor.
-[ Laughs ]
That is correct.
Well, you've built this
giant culinary brand cookbooks.
You sent me some awesome stuff,
by the way,
and I still use everything.
You have food shows.
You have the magazine.
No, it's amazing,
and you're brilliant.
You're a great chef,
but on the basketball court,
Steph's nickname is Chef Curry.
Does that make you mad?
[ Laughter ]
-It -- it makes me raise an
eyebrow because I just...
I get it.
He's cooking on the court.
But like, I'm really like,
I'm -- I'm searing
steaks over here.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm actually cooking.
-I don't get it, but we can --
we can share. It's fine.
-Nah, we can't share.
You're giving that answer.
I know happy wife, happy life.
[ Laughter ]
And we had this conversation
because Drake came up
with that line in his song,
you know,
Chef Curry with the pot,
and kind of took off from there.
But the real Chef Curry
is Ayesha,
so I had to relinquish...
That nickname can never be used
for me inside the house.
If it's fan base, cool,
they can use whatever.
But she's the
real Chef Curry.
-Ah, yeah.
That's the way to do it.
[ Applause ]
Good man.
Steph, I want to
congratulate you on --
you recently became the NBA's
all-time leader
in three-pointers made.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean...
you are officially the greatest
shooter in NBA history.
I know you're very humble
about it,
but can we just talk about this?
President Obama disagreed
that -- with that sentiment.
And do you want to clear it up.
-He did.
He took a different spin on it.
He -- obviously,
I have an amazing shooter
and teammate and Klay Thompson,
and we won the Championship
back in 2015,
we went to the White House
to meet him.
And on the podium,
while we're, you know,
celebrating a championship
and the honor
of going to the White House,
he says,
"You know, Steph,
I know you can shoot,
but I think Klay Thompson has a
much prettier form than you do."
And I said, "I can't -- I can't
disagree with you on that.
If I was teaching
somebody how to shoot,
Klay has textbook form.
-But...
-Yeah.
-...you know, I always think
I'm the better shooter, so...
-Yeah, yeah.
You got to call Barack back
and be like,
"Hey, you saw what I --
You saw what I did, right?"
Yeah, okay, yeah.
I want to talk about your new
show, "About Last Night."
It is so fun.
It's a --
it's a game night
with celebrity couples.
Ayesha, where did
the idea come from?
-So, it's actually a reboot
of a show that aired
for like 10 seasons in the '70s
called "Tattletales,"
and it's just so light hearted
and fun,
gives you a little insight into,
you know, relationships that you
wonder about, but in a fun way.
And just with the -- with
this climate right now,
the world we're living in,
it's nice to just have something
where you can kind of just sit
down and have a good laugh.
-I want to show everyone
a clip of the show.
Okay, here is a sneak peek
of "About Last Night."
Take a look
-Who's better at dirty talk?
-Dang.
-Damn.
Five for five?
[ Laughter ]
-God.
-Hold my things.
-We got you, we got you.
Hold on, stay there.
-Are you serious?
-You got that one?
-I got yours.
-Y'all go five for five.
-Sheesh.
-We got all five right?
-All five of them.
-You got all five.
[ Laughter ]
Which means you get extra five
for you charity.
It must be the newlywed bliss.
-Yeah, it is.
Y'all go back upstairs, man.
Y'all get upstairs.
-So, let's look
at these cameras off
and get the real party started.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's fun, it's fun.
Stephen and Ayesha Curry,
everyone.
"About Last Night"
begins streaming
February 10th on HBO Max.